في بلادي مركوتين مقتله مالك ومؤسس مجموعه
فاجنرى تحطم طائراته فوق موسكو مساء
الاربعاء وقدم بوتين تعزيه لعائله مؤسس
فاجنر وبقيه ضحايا الحادث ومن بينهم نائب
بريغوجين
لمح مسؤولون غربيون لمسؤوليه الكرملين عن
الحادث
اذا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام كان ذكاء
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
هي الاسباب التي ادت الى تاخير سلطات
الروسيه الاعلان عن مصير بريجين وما الذي
يضيف هذا التاخير الى الجدل بشان ظروف
وملابسات تحطم طائرته فوق موسكو مساء
الاربعاء ما هي الجهات المستفيده من غياب
بريكوجين ونائبه عن المشهد في روسيا وكيف
سيؤثر غيابهما بهذه الطريقه الماساويه على
علاقه فاجنر بالكرملين في الفتره المقبله
وكيف نقرا ردود الفعل الروسيه والغربيه
على حادثه بريغوجين وكيف يمكن ان يتم
توظيفها في سياق الحرب على اوكرانيا وفي
اطار صراع النفوذ بين موسكو واشنطن في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا بعد نحوي يوم كامل من تحطم الطائره
الخاصه لمؤسسي ومالك مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
الامنيه الخاصه
فوق موسكو وبعد غموض لفه مصيره ومصيره
نائبه ديمتري اوتاكين وعدد من قيادات
المجموعه الاخرى اعلن الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين مقتل بريغوجين وبقيه من
كانوا معه على متن الطائره من خلال تقديم
تعزيه لعائلات ضحايا حادثه الطائره بوتين
تعهد بالمضي قدما بالتحقيق في الحادثه حتى
النهايه وفق قوله لكنه لم يوجه اصابع
الاتهام لاي جهه بشان الحادثه واشاد بوتين
الذي قال انه يعرفه منذ حقبه التسعينيات
ووصفه بانه كان رجل اعمال موهوبا
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
الدكتور رولاند
المحلل السياسي ومن بروكسل تنضم الينا
تيريزا فعلا مديره مركز روسيا اوروبا
واسيا للدراسات مرحبا بكم سنبدا معك
رولاند بيدجيا موف اكثر من 24 ساعه مضت
على سقوط هذه الطائره ما الذي ادى الى
تاخير الاعلان عن وفاه بريغوجين باعتقادك
تحياتي لضيفك الكريمه لفريق القناه
وللمشاهدين بطبيعه الحال دائما لم عندما
تحدث هذه الاحداث هذا السؤال يطرح لماذا
بوتين
لم يعلن شيئا اولا هذه هي طريقه بوتين
واسلوبه هو رجل حاديه اكيد هو كان على علم
بما حدث ولكن هو دائما ينتظر النتيجه
النهائيه
لكي تكون عنده اي اثباتات ويتحدث بعد ذلك
ولكنه كنا نعلم ذلك منذ الامس عندما اعلنت
مؤسسه الطيران الروسيه روساوي ان وقوي
حادثين وقيل انه هناك اسم
وغيرهم من الاسماء اله قائمه رك هذه
الطائره امبراير واعتقد انه هناك هذا
الجواب مفيد
ويمكن ان ننتقل الى
الاسئله الاخرى
ما هو مصير واغنير وماذا سيحدث وما هي
التبعيات بهذا الاسئله سيد
ولكن دعنا نسال السيده تيريزا فعلا عن
رايها
ما حدث
التاخير في الاعلان عن رغم القول او او
معرفه انه كان من ركاب هذه الطائره منذ
سقوطها بالامس والاسلوب الذي جرى به قبل
قليل الاعلان عن مقتله ما الرسائل كما
قراتها من ورق من وراء كل ذلك
اعتقد ان المهم جدا ان نتذكر ان وهو
المؤسس الاخر كان على الرحله بالتالي في
انفجار واحد قاموا بالقضاء على نفس الشيء
يقال ان الانتقام افضل ياتي باردا بعد
شهرين من المحاوله الانقلاب التي قادها
وتحركه نحو موسكو والكثير شك ان هذا الامر
سيحصل لكنها كانت فقط مساله وقت بالتالي
الكثير بتفاجاوا كيف التقى مع بوتين لشرب
الشاي لركنها ربما كانت طريقه بوتين من
اجل استعاده السيطره على فيغنر لان هنالك
الكثر
همدون بالولاء
لبرجوشن علينا ان نتذكر الصور التي ظهرت
من الكثير من الناس كانوا يبقون ويضعونه
الزهور كان بالتالي بوتين في كان ان يسيطر
على
وبالتالي كانت هذه طريقته
هو واجهت هذه المجموعه المهمه لكن يبدو ان
الان هذه المجموعه تمحييدها وهو ايضا
تحذير لكل مناوئ لبوتين وروسيا هذه رساله
مفادها عليكم الا تحاولوا اي شيء تقوم باي
شيء ضدها لانكم ستواجهون مصيرا مؤلما ما
الذي دفعك الى الوصول الى هذه الاستنتاجات
سيده فعلا
نعم هو صندوق اسود علينا ان نراقب ونعرف
ونتنبا ما الذي سيحصل لكن الرئيس بوتين
يحتاج
مجموعه فاقنا لانها لعبه دورا مهما في
افريقيا وفي اوكرانيا بالتالي راينا ان
بريكوشن ينتقل في انواع انحاء مختلفه في
في البلاد وكان ايضا ربما محاوله لجمع
التعاطف لكن يبدو انه في نهايه المطاف فان
بريكوجين كان له وقت محدد وكان كما تنبا
الكثيرون انه كان هنالك
تقارير استخباراتيه ايضا
بالتالي كان هو يحاول ان يرتب الامور وفي
نهايه المطاف بوتين تمكن
من ان
يخفف ويواجه هذا الهجوم على سلطته اعتقد
الكثر ان بوتين كان في موقف ضعيف لكنه
الان هو يمتلك كله البطاقات وموت
بهذه الطريقه كان هنالك اشاعات انه كان
هنالك صاروخان عسكريان لم يظهر في
تم سماعه
اشخاص هذا الامر يعطي مؤشرا انه ربما
الجيش الروسي اسقط هذه الطائره علينا
تكسر السيناريوهات حول كيفيه حدوث هذا
السقوط لهذه الطائره ان كان سقوطا ام
اسقاطا متعمدا يقول مسؤولان
امريكيانس انه جرى اسقاطها او واشنطن
تعتقد انه جرى اسقاطها عبر اطلاق صاروخ
ارض جو عليها كيف تتعامل روسيا مع كل هذه
الفرضيات وما رايك انت كيف اتبعت كل ما
جرى الحديث عنه بشان هذا الحادث
في رائع المتواضعيه كرجل الذي خدم في
الدفاع الجوي في ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
استطيع ان اقول لكم انه هذا غير ناتج ان
ان الصاروخ او اسقاط لم يكن هناك الاسقاط
اعصابت اصيبت هذه الطائره بصاروخ لم تكن
الشظايا مثل هذه القطع الكبيره التي وقع
وزنا على الارجح كانت هناك
عمليه التي نفضتها الجحا محنيه جدا عن
طريقه التوجير
احدى الفرضيات كانت انه في اخر اللغدة ما
نقلي صندوق او كرتونه شامبوانيا الى الى
الطائره في اخر اللقطه قبل اقلاوها وربما
كانت المتفجرات فيها وهذا على فكره
الاسلوب الذي كان متبع في اختيار
وغيرهم من الاشخاص
شخصيات البارزه في روسيا وبالمناسبه اليد
المخابرات الاوكرانيه لان في طواطنين
يونيو
رئيس المخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه كان
يوعد بانه سيكون هناك يلمح بان تكون هناك
القصص الكبيره والاحداث الكبيره في روسيا
وبالمناسبه حدث
ذلك امس قبيل على وشك ايدي الاستقلال
الاوكراني
الذي تحتفل به اوكرانيا اليوم وبلا شك هذه
هي
هديه
للاوكرانيين في هذا ظرف لان بريكوشن
بالنسبه لهم الرمز
الفرضيه وقول فلودي مرزلين كان رئيس
الاوكراني انه لا علاقه لاوكرانيا بهذا
المقتل الذي وصفه بالمزعوم ليبريغوجين
كذلك هل
هل
يقول انه نفذ هذه الاعلام الماليه لا على
ذلك ابتداء من السيد بايدن وغيرهما الجميع
يلقون اللوم
بالطرف الروسي وفي الدرجه الاولى السيد
بوتين ولكن لا اعتقد انا هذه الفرضيه
لديها اساس لان كل هذه التخمينات
تصب في منطق افلام مافيا
ولكن
اشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل الذي نراه
الامر
بينما نتحدث اليك نيويورك تايمز نقلا عن
مسؤولين امريكيين تقول ان وقوعا انفجار
داخل طائره بريغوجين هو الفرضيه الرئيسيه
وقد يكون ناجما عن قنبله اذا وقوع انفجار
داخل الطائره وفق مسؤولين امريكيين هو
الفرضيه الرئيسيه الان لدى واشنطن كما
تقول
طيب في نفس السياق الذي نتحدث به سيد
رولاند بيجاموف
نسال من هي الجهات المستفيده الان من غياب
بريغوجين عن الساحه
صراحه كانت لديه الاعضاء
الكثيرون ليس فقط في اوكرانيا ولكن ايضا
في الجانب الروسي لابد من الاعتراف انها
كانت هناك
بعضها الشخصيات واباض والحركات غير راضيه
من
تصرفاته
وخاصه بعد محاوله التمرد التي حصلت في
يونيو هناك شعبيه
خبطت في هذه الفتره ولكن في كل حال من
الاحوال يجب ان لا ننسى
بوتين جلس مع بريغوجين وتم وقف القضيه
الجنائيه التي فتحت ضده والتحقيق
وبريغوجين خطي الان يعتبر بطلا لروسيا
ومعه جميع الاوسمه وكان يتحرك في روسيا
وبيلاروسيا وافريقيا
لم تكن في لم يكن في صالخ بوتين يعني
استبعاد بمثل هذه الطريقه اولا
من
لاستبعاد القاء اي ظلال اي شبه ضده ثانيا
بوتين نفذ عمليه دقيقه جدا يعني فصل هو
بين
العدوين بين بريغوجين وبين وزير الدفاع
الشورجي
الامور في الجبهه الاوكرانيه
كان عنده اتجاه اخر وهو القارئ الافريقيه
وايضا بيلاروس وشركات بريغوجين على رغم
اننا بعض منها يعني تم تقليص التمويل ولكن
كان متفائلا وكانت امامه الافق الوارده
للعمل في القاره الافريقيه واخر الشريط تم
تصويره في افريقيا ولذلك الان تطرح
الاسئله
سيكون مصير
هذه المعلومات كلها للسيده سيده تيريزا
اذا يقول لنا ضيفنا من روسيا
رتب الاوضاع من بعد التمرد الذي حصل بمعنى
ان وزاره الدفاع تسلمت ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا
ورتب وضع
بريكوجين بحيث اصبح هو يتولى الشؤون في
بيلاروسيا وفي افريقيا بالتالي الان غيابه
عن الساحه من المستفيد منه باعتقادك
اريد فقط ان اذكر نقطه ان بريجوجل
والعصيان الذي قام به كان
بريجوشن قام
باطلاقي النار على طائرات روسيه بالتالي
كان هنالك سيناريو ان هذا ما يبرر استهداف
طائرته هذه احدى النظريات التي ذكرت على
قناه فاجنار من قبل بعض العسكريين في
فاقنار وايضا باستطاعه ان اذكر من ضيفكم
الاخر انه كان هذا نهجا ذكيا من بوتين ان
يبعد نفسه من اجل ان يلوم الاوكرانيين
مثلا لانه يحتاج الى دعم مجموعه فاجنر هو
لا يريد ان يظهر على انه لديه اي يد في ما
حصل وايضا في مجموعه
في قناتهم يعتقدون انها اسقطت من قبل
القوات الروسيه بالتالي فكره ان بوتين كان
يحاول ان يضم مجموعه الى الجيش الروسي ولم
ينجح في هذا الامر بالتالي هو يريد ان
يظهر بمظهر انه يريد ان يعمل مع مجموعه
فاجنر ويريد ان يكون لهم دور في افريقيا
وفي سوريا وفي بعض الاماكن الاخرى بالتالي
انا افتهم افهم المقاربه التي اتى بها
الريف الاخير ان بوتين ليس له اي علاقه
بما حدث لكن اعتقد انه حتى في المقابله
المشهوره قال انه لن انه لا يسامح ابدا
الخيانه الان بعد ان حدث ما حدث غياب
بريكوجين مقتل بريجوجين عفوا وايضا مقتل
نائبه
باعتقادك كيف سيؤثر ذلك على مجموعه فاجنر
وعلى علاقه هذه المجموعه
من الصعب يتنبا لان هنالك الكثير ما يحدث
هو خلف الكواليس وغير معروف لكنني اعتقد
ان بوتين وايضا مساعد حاولوا ان يقوموا
بتضليل الاشخاص الذين يدونون له بالولاء
لانهم يريدون ان يعملوا مع الجيش الروسي
ومع بوتين لان فاجنر يتم اعتبارهم على
انهم وحده منفصله لكنها تدين بالولاء
للحكومه الروسيه بالتالي سنرى ربما ظهورا
للقاده المستقبلين لقياده فاجنر علينا ان
ننتظر لنرى ذلك ونرى اذا ما كان جنود
واعضاء سيصدقون هذا الامر ماذا عن رؤيتك
وقراءتك لذلك سيد بيتجاموف تاثير مقتل
بريكوجين ونائبه على هذه المجموعه مجموعه
فاغنر لا سيما وانها يعني في الاونه
الاخيره اصبحت
ذراعا مهمه لروسيا في توسيع نفوذها لسيما
في افريقيا
فيما يتعلق المسرح الاوكراني لا توجد هناك
اي قيمه مضافه اما فيما يتعلق افريقيا بلا
شك
تلعب دورا مهما في الدول التي
التجات قيادتها الا هذه المجموعه العسكريه
الى هذه الشركه ودائما هناك مساران مسار
الخارجيه الروسيه هو المسار السياسي وهناك
المسار مسار شركه وغيرها من الشركات
العسكريه
والخبراء وبلا شك يعني
الضربه ضد فاغنر تواط في حاله ذاتها
الضربه ضد النفوس الروسي في افريقيا لان
تواجد هذه الشركه العسكريه في بعض الدول
في شمال افريقيا خاصه هو
لديه الدور وهو لابد من ان ناخذ في اين
الاعتبار عند الدراسه
التحليليه ووضع سينريات مستقبليه لانه
بالفعل الشركه تلعب دورا فيما يتعلق
الخدمات الامنيه وايضا هناك شركات اخرى
مربوطه بها
والتي تعمل في بعض فروع الانتاج
والمشاريع المشتركه
وغيرها من المشاريع في كل حال من الاحوال
مستقبل واجنر هذا شيء مهم انا في اعتقادي
الشركه ستستمر على الرغم من انها راسها
الكاريزماطي السيد بريغوجين اليوم نستطيع
ان نقول حتى الان لا توجد نتائج الدينيه
ولكن 99%
احتمال بانه تمت عمليه اغتياله وجميع
الفرضيات الاخرى هناك الناس يصلوا الى
درجه
الذي يظهر على شاشتنا نقلا عن رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه يقول لا علاقه
للولايات المتحده على الاطلاق بتحطم طائره
بريغوجين اذا لا علاقه المتحده على
الاطلاق بتحطم طائره بريغوجين سيد رولان
سابقى معك في موضوع الفرضيات
والسيناريوهات المحتمله بعض الجهات لمحت
الى امكانيه قيام مجموعه فاقنا ربما
بالانتقام لمقتل قائدها في داخل روسيا
سيناريو ربما يشبه ما حدث اثر التمرد الذي
كان حصل قبل شهرين ما احتماليه ذلك
اولا فيما يتعلق الشركه يعني نفسه تم
استبعاده
استبعادهم من المجال السياسي يعني طموحات
اذا كانت عنده طموحات هناك الحديث نوعا من
غيرها ولكن في نهايه المطاف كان انسان
مفتوح
وكان واضح وصريخ جدا مع اصدقائه
واعضائه وكان انسانا مخلصا
لبوتين وقبل كل شيء قبل بوت وكان مخلصا
لوطنه الام روسيا المشكله اللي كانت
هي كانت المشكله الاشكاليه مع
البيروقراطيه العسكريه كما ان كان يطلق
عليها وعلى راسها الوزير الشويجو ورئيس
هيئه الاركان دراسه هي كانت المشكله وتم
حل هذه المشكله
بوساده الرئيس لوكاشنكا وطبعا
بالتنسيق مع بوتين نوسه
قام باداره الازمه هذه الازمه
التي حدثت في يونيو
بمهاره ووفان
والشياخه ولكن لا اعتقد كانت لديها اي خطط
للانتقام
هذا شيء يمكن ان نستبعده كليا لان نراقب
انكتب هناك قنوات تيليجرام عديده احيانا
يقولون انه قال وهم قالوا ولكن معظم هذه
القنوات هي قنوات مزوره الشركه الاساسيه
ليست لديها اي مشكله مع الحكومه وما
الرئيس لا توجد هناك اي تحركات
ولا توجد اي تصريحات
الرئيس بوتين وفيما يتعلق الاطراف الغربيه
ايضا نحيكم ان اشير وانا حتى الان الجانب
الروسي الرئيس بوتين والقياده حتى الان لم
يتم اطلاء
اتهام اي جهه غربيه في تنفيذه هذه العمليه
حتى
اخبار العاشره التي تظهر على الشاشه حسب
اخبار العاجله التي تظهر على شاشتنا ايضا
نقلا عن رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه يقول مقتل بريغوجين سيكون له
تداعيات في مناطق وجود فاغنر في العالم
ووجه اليك السؤال
ما نوع هذه التداعيات
بمقتل بريغوجين على
فاجنر في العالم التي يلمح اليها رئيس
هيئه الارك ان الامريكيه المشتركه
علينا ان نواجه الحقيقه معظم المحللين
كانت هذه
كان هذا امرا ريما للغايه منذ العصيان
ممدوح الانقلاب كان على الجميع ان يخمن
بالتالي كان صعبا على المحللين ان يخمنوا
ما الذي سيحدث بعض المحللين قالوا
هو رجل ميت يسير وبعده يوم امس كان نعرف
انهم كانوا محقين بالتالي هذه هو الشيء
الذي يحصل في
ما يتعلق بالحياه العسكريه في روسيا هنالك
الكثير من الامور الغامضه وهو امر مخيفه
علينا ان نخمن ما الذي يحصل في الكرم لان
مثلا وربما المعاملات المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه قد يكون من الصعب جمعها
راينا الكثير مثلا من الصور لفاقنار ومن
بوتين وولايه
من الخطر ان نقوم باي تنبؤ في هذا المجال
لكنني ساقول انه خلال الشهرين الذي التي
مضت اعتقد انه حاول ان يسيطر حول ان يسيطر
على فيغنار هذا الامر سيستمر واعتقد ان
هذا امر اساسي من اجل الحفاظ على تاثير
روسيا في افريقيا هنالك بعض الادله ان
مجموعه فاجنر تقوم بحمايه الاستثمارات
الصينيه في افريقيا بالتالي هذا الامر
يظهر كيف ان العلاقات الروسيه الصينيه كيف
انها مهمه وكائنات يتم استخدام فاجنر
بطريقه مهمه لحمايه هذه المصالح بالتالي
انا اتوقع انه سيكون هنالك استمرار لهذا
الامر سيكون من الصعب بالتاكيد ايجاد
مجموعه بديله
لكرملين تريد ان تقوم كانت محاوله لضمي
هذه المجموعه الى الجيش الروسي ولم تنجح
بالتالي كان هنالك
اساليب بديله وايضا لكنهم يريدون السيطره
عليها في نفس الوقت لانهم يحتاجون الى
خبره هؤلاء المقاتلين الطويله لا يريد ان
يستبعدهم تماما طيب ماذا سيده تنازع عن
الردود الفعل الغربيه حياه ما حدث ماذا
قرات في طياتها خصوصا ان معظمها اتهم
بطريقه او باخرى الكريم بالوقوف وراء ما
جرى
لقد قرات كل ما استطعت ان اراه في الصحف
وفي الاعلام احدى الامور التي قلت ان ذكرت
ان ذيل الطائره كان بعيدا عن موقع التحكم
بالتالي كان هنالك نظريات باسقاطها او
اطلاق النار عليها واعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده لديها بعض المعلومات من الاقمار
الصناعيه وايضا كان هنالك بث يتحدث عن
تفجير من قنبله داخل الطائره لكن الاشخاص
الذين كانوا على الارض سمعوا صوتين صوت
انفجارين بالتالي سنحصل على معلومات
اضافيه في المستقبل لكن اعتقد ان الامر قد
حسم وان بوتين
وقد ابعد نفسه عن هذا الموضوع هو يعرض
مواساته ويريد ان يظهر بدوره
سيده تيريزا ماذا تقول لنا ردود الفعل
بالطريقه التي
وردت به من الدول الغربيه
وماذا تقول لنا عن تاثير ما حدث على الحرب
على اوكرانيا
التاثير على الحرب في اوكرانيا لا اعتقد
انه سيكون له تاثير كبير على الحرب فاغنار
كانت
ستستمر بارسال القوه تعتقد ان
كان يعتبر
كان قد قام باشياء مروعه في فتره حياته
واعتقد ان الناس في اوكرانيا يشعرون
بالراحه لكنهم بالتاكيد سيكون هناك شخص
اخر يحل محل بالتالي الحرب ستستمر في
اوكرانيا واعتقد انه سيكون لها تاثير كبير
لما حدث لكن ان مجموعه فاقنال اعتقد انه
قد يتم استخدامهم لكن علينا ان ننتظر كيف
ان فاجنر مجموعه فاجنر ستصدق هذه النظريه
هل سيكون هنالك حديث او شكوك اذا ما كان
اثبات انه قد تم قد اغتيل من اعتقد انه
سيكون له تاثير على المجموعه
اشكركما من بروكسل تيريزا فعلا مديره
مركزي روسيا اوروبا واسيا للدراسات وشكرا
لضيفنا من موسكو الدكتور رونالدز بيتجاموف
المحلل السياسي كان ضيفنا من موسكو
مشاهدينا بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام هذه
الحلقه ممسكوها الدكتور رولاند بيتجموف
المحلل السياسي كان ضيفنا من موسكو
مشاهدينا بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نشكر لكم
متابعتكم